the Buckeye women's prison in Istanbul
Ali recital ooh comes here regularly to
visit his daughter mashaallah this time
he plans to take his two and a half year
old grandson with him when he leaves
Serkan lives together with his mother in
jail after their half-hour visit the boy
is carried out by his aunt many other
family members are waiting for them
outside they're looking forward to
spending the weekend with Serkan when I
get to see my grandchild I'm very happy
if rainy then I'm so pleased I feel like
the luckiest man in the whole world
mashaallah tano was arrested on April
30th and has been in detention ever
since
Turkey's public prosecutor accuses her
of disseminating terrorist propaganda
and being a member of a terrorist
organization
Tolu who only holds German citizenship
worked as a journalist and translator
for a leftish Turkish news agency before
spending the weekend with his
grandparents second visits his father
who was active in a Socialist Party he
was arrested shortly before his wife was
now in Sylvia prison he's also accused
of belonging to a terrorist group it's
not much of a childhood for a
two-year-old living with his mother in
one Jail and visiting his father in
another after the visit a lira Sarto Lu
tells us that second and his father were
still separated by a pane of glass this
is the second time I brought him over
here Sakon sees him through the glass
and talks to him over the phone it's not
nice but at least he gets to see his
father he was happy and said daddy when
are you coming back his dad said he's
vacationing here for a while yeah
seconds parents are trying to shield
their son from the reality that they're
both in prison it was his mother's
decision to have second live in the jail
cell with her Ali Riza
talu says that his granddaughter and
grandson are being well treated still
spending the weekend outside prison Wars
is important for the child's development
alehrer Santa Lou regularly meets with
his daughter's lawyer
mashaallah tow Lewis trial is set to
begin on October 11th in Istanbul her
lawyer is worried because she says that
right now judges are ruling largely in
favor of the policies of turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan she can
only shake her head at the charges
against her client in 2015 mashaallah
Tolu attended the funerals of two
left-wing extremists belonging to the
outlawed Marxist Leninist communist
party who were killed by police in
Istanbul the same year she also attended
a memorial service for a member of the
Kurdish militia YPG who died in the
fight against is in Syria the events
were an expression of freedom of speech
they took place under the supervision of
Turkish security authorities and ended
peacefully now they're being denounced
as terrorist propaganda and attending
them implies you belong to a terrorist
organization it's time for Serkan to go
back to his mother
Ali recital hopes his daughter will be
released in October after her trial but
he has his doubts about the justice
system the Sultan is immobilizer Berg if
they're always looking for evidence but
there is now they only arrested her to
get revenge on Germany or something
Turkey's government swears that the
country's judiciary is independent
mashallah toulouse lawyer says that if
the judge rules in accordance with the
law the journalist and her son should be
out of jail in October